first of all congrats on the movie it's
fantastic I'm sure you're hearing that
from everybody so I just want to start
with that you guys both have a pretty
big following on Instagram I am curious
how much debate do you have before
hitting post quite a lot I'm so bad with
social media and I have no idea what to
say ever so I'll let other people make
the decisions for me and I'll press the
post button after they figured out yeah
I'm terrible yeah you're not alone in
that by the way
ya know you're a hundred percent not we
it was funny because we were talking
about this before and like I was saying
I love the element of being able to
connect with fans and that's why I have
it but I feel like you start filtering
yourself not for likes but just because
I noticed that like if I did certain
things that would like I've personally
like maybe people would then know where
I was and and that wasn't always the
best but yeah I feel like there's a lot
of deliberation now but I genuinely love
connecting with people so if I don't
know there's a way to merge those two
and a happy medium I'd like to but yeah
it's really weird it's you came up to me
once when we were oh my god I did and
you're really good okay what what do I
put it in black and white or do I do it
in this filter I was like I want to
connect with people but I also like
don't want to give too much information
like yeah you made a good choice thank
you teamwork yeah I have to talk about
Ryan's script
it's like scripts like this don't come
along that often for you guys what was
it like reading it for the first time
and were you able to put it together as
you were reading or with it only when
you got to the end the script came it's
such a weird time for me I don't know
about you but for like I think I said
this before like but like I was mu I
moved so much last year like I was in a
different place every nine days for ten
months and yeah that and I was ready to
go home when I got this script and it
something literally I was ready to go
home but it made me stay because it was
just something that I read and felt so
fresh and yes it was a it was a mystery
and I think you're driven by that thrill
and you're driven by the want to find
out but at the same time it was also
something it didn't feel like a wait for
an answer it felt like every moment was
engaging or funny and the way that Ryan
wrote the script I think which isn't
kind of an homage to him and just being
the clever and wonderful passionate
filmmaker that he is but also
screenwriter is that the way that it
read on the page you could almost like
hear it you could hear it and see it
almost in a way like how it was going to
be in film so that was really I think
engaging and cool and different
yeah like you were saying I think the
the special thing about this movie is
with a lot of whodunits you're trying to
get you start from a and then you're
trying to get to B and you could skip
over everything in between and figure
out who did it but with this there's so
many different paths and and it just
takes you on a wild ride and I wanted to
be a part of it and this isn't once in
the life opportunity but once in a
lifetime opportunity they get to work
with these amazing people and and Ryan